dix d'entre eux monsieur le ministre ma
question porte sur la fusion des
rectorat de nice et d'aix marseille et
par conséquent sur l'éventuelle
suppression de l'académie de nice en
juillet 2018 vous avez annoncé vouloir
une seule académie par région pourtant
lors de votre venue à nice au début de
l'année
vous aviez d'abord penché en faveur d'un
simple rapprochement des services
si la décision de fusion devait être
confirmée les professeurs les proviseurs
et les personnels des établissements
actuellement placé sous la
responsabilité du rectorat de nice
perdrait inévitablement en proximité
pour la mise en oeuvre des politiques
éducatives en matière d'examen aussi un
rectorat unique redéfinir et sous
l'autorité du recteur le service du
département des examens et des concours
notamment pour le passage du
baccalauréat et du brevet de plus si
certains postes devaient être transférés
à plusieurs centaines de kilomètres de
distance
ce sont autant de foyers qui seront
impactées par cet éloignement alors que
leur vie quotidienne s'organise à nice
ou dans les communes voisines
si le rappeur veille préconise un
rectorat unique par nouvelles régions la
région sud est un territoire densément
peuplées les effectifs des deux rectorat
d'aix-marseille et de nice
additionnez donne un ensemble proche
d'une académie francilienne mais dans le
cadre d'un territoire qui est à la fois
plus vaste et mixtes mélangeant vous le
savez des zones urbaines denses et des
zones rurales et de montagne
si cette justification découle de
l'application du nouveau cadre régional
fixée par la loi de 2015 relatives au
redécoupage des 17 régions la région sud
elle vous le savez très bien n'a pas été
redécoupée géographiquement
alors monsieur le ministre comptez-vous
véritablement fusionner les rectorat de
nice et d'aix marseille
si oui selon quel calendrier quelle est
votre vision de la gouvernance éducative
pour la région sud notamment en matière
de réorganisation administrative
pour ces deux académies dans les
prochaines années la parole est à
monsieur jean michel blanquer ministre
de l'éducation nationale et de la
jeunesse
merci madame la présidente madame la
sénatrice c'est évidemment une question
très importante je suis heureux de
pouvoir m'exprimer sur ce point aussi je
souhaiterais débuté ma réponse par une
analyse de la situation existante tout
le monde reconnaît que la réforme
régionale de 2015 nous a placés dans une
situation intermédiaire aujourd'hui et
parfois dans une ambiguïté dont il faut
savoir sortir
même s'il est exact que qu'il y avait
deux académies pour une région avant
même cette réforme
aujourd'hui les cartes des académies et
des régions métropolitaines ne
correspondent pas et cette situation
n'est pas satisfaisante
à l'heure où l'éducation nationale doit
conduire avec les régions des réformes
d'envergure notamment celle de
l'orientation ou encore celle de la voie
professionnelle
c'est pourquoi nous avons décidé de nous
appuyer sur les recommandations de la
mission que vous avez cités sur la
réorganisation territoriale des services
déconcentrés des ministères de
l'éducation nationale et de
l'enseignement supérieur
conduite par françois weil conseiller
d'état olivier dugrip recteur de
l'académie de bordeaux et deux
inspecteurs généraux de l'éducation
nationale marie pier luigi et alain
perritaz de cette mission je retiens les
grands principes suivants qui conduisent
aujourd'hui à la réforme au 1er janvier
2020 nous avons fixé très clairement
comme objectif qui durait très academy
dirigé par 13 recteur d'académie dans
les 13 régions métropolitaines en
fonction des caractéristiques de chaque
territoire le recteur pour être assisté
d'un adjoint
il n'y a pas de schéma préétabli pas
d'organisation unique a plaqué sur le
territoire nous souhaitons au contraire
que les territoires sortent gagnants de
cette réforme qui pourra d'ailleurs
rééquilibrer certains aspects de la
réforme de 2015 par exemple certaines
fonctions des rectorats pour être
positionné dans des villes qui ne sont
pas les capitales régionales
il est également envisageable de
distinguer rectorat d'académie dans une
ville et chancellerie des universités
dans une autre les objectifs et le
cadrage de la réforme territoriale ont
été fixées par lettre adressée au
recteur par la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur frédéric vidal
et par moi-même
le 19 juillet dernier les recteurs
depuis lors conduisent une large
concertation avec les élus locaux et les
services académiques afin de permettre
d'avoir une feuille de route dès cette
fin d'année 2010 8 et nous annoncerons
les arbitrages au
début de l'année 2019 parallèlement à
cette réforme
je souhaite renforcer l'action
départementale et infra départementale
de l'éducation nationale afin
d'encourager des formules de gestion du
système scolaire au plus près du terrain
et je crois que c'est le coeur de la
réponse à votre question car la première
conséquence de la régionalisation qui a
eu lieu avec la loi de 2015 a été doit
être d'avoir une vision stratégique à
l'échelle de chaque grande région mais
aussi d'avoir des compétences renforcées
à l'échelle de chaque département pour
prendre des décisions pragmatiques au
quotidien dans la lignée de ce que le
président de la république a dit au
congrès de versailles 2 juillet dernier
c'est le cas par exemple aujourd'hui
même dans les expérimentations de
gestion des ressources humaines de
proximité que nous avons commencé à
mener sous le pilotage des recteurs et
des dizaines elles permettent d'
humaniser cette gestion des ressources
humaines et donc madame la sénatrice par
rapport aux exemples que vous avez cités
d'éloignement éventuelle par exemple
pour les examens ou pour la gestion des
ressources humaines
ce que nous visons c'est au contraire
d'aller dans le sens que vous souhaitez
c'est à dire d'avoir jugé minuscule
portion des marques et mentale de
proximité je vous remercie